[Music]
it's great to be here in one of my
favorite cities in the world probably my
favorite city in the world so thank you
the next web for hosting me this has
been a long time coming and I'm thrilled
to be here with you guys today in this
celebration of technology creativity and
innovation so for those who don't know
my name is Jason Silva I am the host of
national Geographics brain games which
is a television show that looks at our
perceptions of reality but also our
misperceptions of reality and there are
a lot of misperceptions particularly in
the realm of Technology and innovation
and this is kind of what I like to walk
you through today so this all starts for
me with a passion for human creativity
an absolute passion for human
imagination our capacity to engender
visions in our minds I and bring those
visions into fruition and this passion
for creativity and for imagination has
turned into a passion for technology
because I believe that technology is
imagination literalized I believe that
technology is the embodiment of human
creativity in the world I believe that
technology is how we turn the human mind
inside out and it's how we impregnate
the world with mind the cognitive
philosophers David Chalmers and Andy
Clark and their seminal essay the
extended mind thesis these guys describe
technology as a scaffolding of mind that
we use to extend our thoughts our reach
and our vision right and it has always
been so we are a tool making animal as
Marshall McLuhan famously said we build
the tools and then the tools build us if
you go back a hundred thousand years
the savannahs of Africa when early
hominids were crawling the land and they
first picked up a stick on the ground
and used that stick to reach a fruit
that was on a really high tree branch
we've been using our instruments our
tools our sticks to extend our reach to
overcome our boundaries right to
transcend and overcome our limitations
that is what we have always done
Ray Kurzweil has a wonderful line it
says this capacity to imagine things in
these virtual realities in our
imagination right in combination with
our modest-looking sums was sufficient
to usher in this secondary force of
evolution we call technology and it will
continue until the entire universe is at
our fingertips so technology has always
changed the world technology has always
disrupted the status quo technology has
always redefined what it means to be
human but these changes these
redefinitions they happened over many
many generations and so the world didn't
really change very much within one's own
lifespan and so these disruptions
weren't as visceral as they are now but
now it's very different now the changes
are happening in real time it's like
time-lapse photography the pace of
change itself is accelerating so rapidly
that the feeling of vertigo has become
very real the world is changing before
our very eyes so it's no longer
historical anecdote it's real time it's
happening and we are jolted the feeling
of disruption the feeling of the rug
being pulled from underneath our feet is
very very real today and the question is
why right technology has always changed
the world why does it seem to be
speeding up well this is where things
get exciting technology is speeding up
because technology advances or
accelerates exponentially but human
beings are linear thinkers that's the
reason we never see the future coming
the brain evolved in a world that was
linear and that was local and now we
live in a world that is global
and that is exponential so we have these
linear lenses in an exponential world so
we never see the future coming our
expectations are always wrong because
our intuition about change is always
wrong so what's the difference right I
mean this was the metaphor that really
created that cognitive leap for me it's
an example used by Ray Kurzweil he wrote
the seminal book The Singularity is near
when humans transcend biology makes
lavish predictions about the future and
he's now the head of engineering at
Google so the guy's no joke and he uses
an example in his lectures and I've used
this example for years and it works
really quickly to wrap your head around
the implications of exponential progress
so if you take 30 linear steps 30 linear
steps one two three four five you get to
30 30 linear steps gets you to 30 and
that is our intuition about change over
time right but if you take the same
amount of steps same amount of steps 30
steps but their exponential steps now
you get to a billion in those 30 steps
so 30 linear steps gets you to 30 30
exponential steps gets you to a billion
and technology changes exponentially
that's the reason why the smartphone in
your pocket today is a million times
cheaper a million times smaller and a
thousand times more powerful than what
used to be a 60 million dollar
supercomputer that was half a building
in size forty years ago so take that in
for a second try to appreciate that
amount of progress that astounding
amount of progress of acceleration what
used to be the size of this arena 40
years ago that's 60 million dollar
mainframe supercomputer that you needed
special permission to get access to has
shrunk down to a device that fits in
your pocket million times cheaper
million times smaller and a thousand
times more powerful that's exponential
change an exponential change doesn't end
right it continues to compound in the
next
25 years this will shrink down most
likely to a device the size of a blood
cell it'll go in our bodies and brains
reverse-engineering us from inside out
but of course your linear brain kicks in
right away and you're like oh no no no
no no and it'll never happen but it's
already been happening look how far
we've come look how fast we've gotten
here so if you guys are technologists
and entrepreneurs excited about the next
big thing you want to start thinking
exponentially you want to start
leveraging exponential change for good
for impact for scale right instead of
being scared by the disruptions of our
age instead of being frightened or
jolted by the fear that your jobs are
gonna go away you need to embrace
exponential change you need to become an
exponential thinker all right so you can
author the world you want into being so
again these technologies are advancing
exponentially our capacity to impact the
world is advancing exponentially I
traveled around the world I try to
explain these ideas to corporations and
people to get them beyond the bin
there's and done that's of the adult
mind because this really requires almost
a child's eye view of what might be we
need to stretch our imaginations to
think exponentially once a mind is
stretched by a new idea it never returns
to its original position right and so
people often tell me okay fine
exponential change pretty amazing pretty
discombobulating to really just assume
the implications of that change
but that's information technology right
what about what about the world that we
dwell in the physical world what about
the world of flesh what about the world
of concrete that's still a slow-moving
world well here's what gets really
sci-fi ask because the world of flesh
and the world of concrete are both now
becoming information technologies
and so what that means is that they are
now subject to the same exponential
progress that we've seen in information
tech in digital tech software really is
eating the world
let's take biology for starters so in
the realm of information technology
biology is now referred to as bio
technology biotechnology means mastering
the information processes of biology it
turns out that we are linguistic all the
way down turns out we are made of code
DNA is code our genes are little
software programs and these software
programs are increasingly becoming
programmable we are made of language and
we are increasingly harnessing our
creative capacity to author and
transform the very language of biology I
remember this wonderful line by the
physicist Freeman Dyson in an essay on
the age of biology as he called it where
he envisioned a very near future where a
new generation of artists and poets
would be writing genomes with the
fluency that Blake and Byron wrote
versus think about that for a second the
canvas of life itself becoming a canvas
for our artistry and our creativity and
as it turns out just as one example gene
sequencing the speed at which we can
sequence our genes is advancing three
times faster than those exponential
numbers I listed before so gene
sequencing is progressing three times
faster than exponential there's a reason
why Larry Page the co-founder of Google
created calico California life extension
company a software company for biology
right cuz that's the new hackable space
that's the new Silicon Valley obsession
to hack deaths they scored a Time
magazine cover story called Google in
the end of death reprogramming biology
could mean the end of diseases the end
of cancer the beginning of a world
you can download software patches for
biology the next trillion-dollar
hackable entrepreneurial space the new
Silicon Valley will be the biology
Valley it's going to change healthcare
it's going to change what it means to be
human it's going to give us authorship
over our own species talk about the
human mind turns inside out our
imagination has now become a force that
can affect biology itself and again it's
advancing faster than exponential then
you have nanotechnology nanotechnology
essentially takes the atoms the building
blocks of the physical world and
patterns and programs those atoms the
same way we program and pattern ones and
zeroes with digital technology so take
that metaphor from digital tech ones and
zeroes that create the whole world of
digital and apply that into the metaphor
of programming atoms that's
nanotechnology right the seminal book on
nanotechnology was called engines of
creation and that's literally what
nanotechnology is the engines of
creation the physical world becomes a
programmable medium as the psychedelic
philosopher Terence Mckenna said if the
world becomes the condensation of human
imagination there is poetry and what
becomes possible what we can offer when
we can play and pattern atoms the world
of scarcity that we live in today
disappears Peter Diamandis and Steven
kotler's book abundance why the future
will be better than you think talks
about how resource care city is
contextual and technology is a resource
liberating mechanism well when you can
pattern atoms using nanotechnology you
can turn anything into anything else how
does that change what becomes possible
so you have these exponentially
advancing technologies you have
biotechnology you have nanotechnology
and of course you have artificial
intelligence which is continuing to
advance exponentially the creation of
non-biological Minds non-biological
intelligence that in symbiosis with
biologic
intelligence creates a hybrid species
really
we are the natural-born cyborgs we
always have been and these three
overlapping revolutions biotech nanotech
and AI are kind of like coalescing
together and when you try to sort of
make projections into the future what
does the world look like on the back of
these three exponential technologies
well in Silicon Valley it's become a
mythology almost like a religion but a
religion built on data-driven
extrapolations right we're looking into
the magic mirror of the future but if we
have the data to back it up and they
call this the singularity what a
mythology for our age singularity is a
metaphor borrowed from physics to
describe what happens when you go
through a black hole namely the laws of
physics as you know them no longer apply
so they've taken that metaphor from
physics and applied it to the world of
technology innovation and creativity as
we continue to essentially turn our
minds inside out and live inside of the
condensation of our own imagination and
be able to realize and engender
our dreams in the world in real-time
well
that's a singularity so I'm a video guy
and I think that storytelling is a huge
part of assuring in this future that we
want I mean technology has always been a
double-edged sword
it's an amplifier of human consciousness
it can extend but it can also amputate
and so I think that the consciousness of
the people in gendering this future is
what we really need to mediate we need
people to be inspired we need people to
be optimistic we need people to be
forward-thinking
with a capital F and a capital T we need
to become exponential thinkers and I
think the most effective way of doing
that is to inspire people and so that's
where my video work comes in I like to
show you a video today it's called the
future of us and it mirrors this idea
that it's always been the artist who
realizes that the future is the present
and he uses his work to prepare the
grounds for it so bring your attention
to the monitors to a video called the
future of us if you can please please so
let's talk about the huge
of us what does that even mean the
future of us it's a look at what comes
next
it's a look at what might be because
today exponentially emerging
technologies are transforming what's
possible they're helping us overcome
transcend even biological limitations
the very rules of what it is to be human
are for grabs we're rewriting the
software of life with biotechnology
you're turning matter into a
programmable medium with
nanotechnologies we're creating sentient
Minds with artificial intelligence that
are not bound by the limitations of
biology these three overlapping
revolutions PN our genetic and of
Technology and robotics together will be
leveraged to lead us towards a black
hole light impossible to fathom
singularity it's like staring into the
Sun um
rousing symphonic climax when all of my
leverage to network together transcends
its biological origins and we become
something more people worry about the
ai's in this end as well as Kurzweil
says that's gonna be us the future of us
is harsh to dream up so let's talk so I
started doing these videos because I
wanted to change the way that people
think about tech and innovation and one
of the key changes in my own thinking
about this came after reading Kevin
Kelley's book what technology wants you
probably saw Kevin speak yesterday what
a marvelous technology technology
philosopher he is and in that book he
put out this idea that technology is
like our second skin he referred to
technology as the seventh kingdom of
life
he called it actually the Technium and
he said that the Technium is subject to
the same poles and evolutionary forces
as biological evolution
so essentially you know people that fear
the technology as being somehow
unnatural or people who worried that
technology somehow it's like tinkering
with the natural order need to realize
that technology emerged from the natural
order because we are the natural order
this is what kevin kelly refers to as
exotropia right it's the opposite of
entropy life moves towards greater
complexity and organization and from
life is born this secondary skin and it
moves towards greater complexity an
organization creating more possibility
in the world and doing so exponentially
and what's fascinating for those that
still think this is unnatural is that
the more are human-made systems become
complex and sublime and self-organizing
the more they're starting to mirror
patterns found in natural systems and so
what we start to see it feels like an
episode of The Twilight Zone it's a bit
psychedelic in fact because it's like
holy the more sublime the stuff we
engender the more it mirrors the natural
world created
kind of ontological awakening when we
come to realize the forceful reckoning
with what's actually going on is we may
not even be in control right it comes
through us but not from us and though it
is with us it belongs not to us this is
just a universe where the conditions are
right for this extra trophic Force this
moves towards more creativity and more
organization maybe possible in this next
video looks exactly at that it's called
to understand is to perceive patterns
please show the next video you know
there's a mind expanding idea that
smashes the false to allottee between
nature and technology the realization
that nature and technology are one and
the same a continuum smack in the middle
between the born and the major this sums
up in the lines to understand is to
perceive patterns that moment when the
dots connect you see that gets down long
view and you see the big picture this
notion of patterns for example Paul
Stamets has written about the mycelial
archetype and how the information
sharing systems that comprise the inner
to demand made system mirror the neurons
in our brain natural system which in
turn mirror computer models of dark
matter in the universe they all share
the exact same intermingled filamentous
structure it's unbelievable or for
example the fact that forwards your ants
when they hunt for food their patterns
of hunting mirror the tcp/ip protocols
that govern information flow of traffic
on the Internet
same patterns jeffrey west through the
Santa Fe Institute tells us that cities
are actually
like organisms they have metabolic rates
and the alleys are like capillaries fly
an airplane look at a city from the sky
it looks like a motherboard it looks
like a microchip information arrange
evolution life sentience mind to
understand is to perceive these patterns
there is no duality between nature and
technology it is all one and the same
thanks guys and so just to wrap up very
quickly there was a campaign put out
there by singularity University which I
think answers the question what do we do
with this power right we are as gods and
might as well get good at it what do we
do when we have the power of gods to
awesome reality to change the world with
our creativity and our innovation and
the idea behind the campaign was to
redefine the term billionaire right
because in the world of startup culture
everybody wants to create the next
company and become the next billionaire
and that's cool right aim high for sure
but what if meant what if being a
billionaire in the age of exponential
technologies was not just making a
billion dollars but what if being a
billionaire meant positively touching a
billion people if you really want to aim
high and you know what to do with all of
this disruption is try to positively
touch a billion brains try to positively
reach a billion minds try to make the
world a little better by aiming to
redefine the term billionaire so I'll
leave you with that I hope you guys all
go out there and change the world thank
you so much for listening I love you so
much thank you guys thanks
thank you
when you the world of exponential
technological advancements what this
literally means that we have new
construction kits for our reality new
tools with which to probe at the
adjacent possible so consider the
implications right as Marshall McLuhan
used to say first we build the tools and
then the tools build us we are designed
by what we have designed there are these
feedback loops of mind tool and world
that radically redefined our boundaries
that radically transform what it means
to be human to be human today is to
criss cross the skies to be human today
is to create techno social wormholes
in these days and so what do we do well
we need to radically reach out to one
another in ways that we haven't before
there's a great line that says empathy
rarely extends beyond our line of sight
in other words it's out of sight it
but if anything is wireless
communication technologies has to not
only review effect we are seeing the big
picture and what shall we do we need to
extend our hands to one another we've
never had such tools to overcome all of
the limitations of our humanity
have the capacity the creative capacity
billions of us leads into one another
global brain what is the new definition
of billionaire the new definition of
billionaire is he who will positively
affect the lives of ability
he or she will reach out and say I will
positively affect the lives for billion
this should be our goal this is our
responsibility here's our chance
[Music]